[Musique]
au bout de téléphone il y à votre voix
et les mots que je ne dirais pas
tous ces mots qui font peur que tu ne
faut pas rire
qui sont en tournée
deux chansons de
faudrait voulait dire
et je voudrais les vivres
je ne ferai pas
je
je ne peux
je suis seul accroc je sais vous
[Musique]
tant d'émoi nous allons
tu peux rêver trop de temps
je voudrais arriver
je reste
et m
je n'arriverais
je
je ne
[Musique]
je devrais arriver
j'ai peur
aso
h
[Musique]
je ne peux pas
temps
mais si tu crois jours que tu m'aimes
ne crois pas que tu aies souvenez le jeu
eneko cours jusqu'à perdre l'est
rien
[Musique]
c'est quoi un jour que tu me
bonjour
la paix
il a tourné
tout ce chemin
viens me la trouver
si le dégoût de la vie
en toi
c'est la masse d'eau
16,2
en
[Musique]
mais si tu crois que tu me
considère pas comme
écoute
jusqu'à paix
ja
c'est croit jour que
[Musique]
m
si le débat
la vie
[Musique]
messi